un tigre au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le capitaine
de la sélection américaine jim furyk a
décidé de sélectionner tiger woods
l'homme aux 14 tournois du grand chelem
pour la ryder cup 2018 fin septembre une
invitation attendu après le bel été du
golfeur sur les meilleurs tournois
mondiaux
il finit fine élan relayé dans les six
premiers à l'open britannique il est
deuxième à lui et spidey
il est toujours devant quoi sûr que
randonnée tiger il revient aux affaires
en plus on sent un joueur en tout cas il
paraît beaucoup plus détendue beaucoup
plus ouvert on sent un joueur qui est
qui et qui est moi qui ai moins tournés
vers lui un peu plus vers les autres et
je pense que ça a dû penchés également
dans la balance dans le dans le choix du
du capitaine américain tiger woods au
golf national ce n'est pas une première
le golfeur avait participé aux
championnats du monde amateurs en 1994
sur le parcours de l'albatros avec
l'américaine avait gagné à le score par
équipes mais il n'avait pas finir les
premiers mails et fait beau tournoi mais
pas fini premiers à première vue
individuel au-delà de l'aspect sportif
la venue du golfeur de 42 ans absent
d'une ryder cup depuis 2012 devrait
doper les audiences sur le circuit
américain le nombre de téléspectateurs
et multiplier par deux camps le tigre et
sur le green qu'on le voit sur les
tournois qui joue sur lesquels il se
remet en mouvement en forme
le dernier a eu à ce budget qui oui fini
deuxième où ils ont battu tous les
records d'audience
tiger woods au graff nationale c'est un
rêve je pense et on pouvait pas rêver
mieux
si les statistiques médiatiques sont du
côté de tiger woods sur le terrain la
ryder cup ne sourit pas aux golfeurs en
sept participations le sportif ne l'a
remporté qu'une seule fois en 1999